simple et hertz
pour la ville de tous les extrêmes
capitale impériale fondée il ya trois
sur les rives de la mer baltique par
pierre le grand elle est déçue sous
l'ère soviétique
depuis peu elle renoue avec son glorieux
passé
aujourd'hui comme hier la ville offre
deux visages aux hiver polaire et leurs
nuits interminables succèdent presque
sans transition des été parfois
caniculaires au jour sans fin un climat
limité à deux saisons très contrastées
auquel les habitants su s'adapter
depuis la chute du communisme de
nombreux pétersbourgeois amoureux de
leur ville participe avec passion à son
nouveau rayonnement
nous avons passé un an auprès de vrais
d'ymir un architecte naval qui se rêve
en pierre le grand et fait construire la
réplique du premier navire de la flotte
russe
le pôle tavannes
il nous faut à tous une goutte de
romantisme un sens de l' aventure avoir
envie de faire renaître le passé yuriy
et sa brigade de sauveteurs plongeurs
eux protègent toute l'année les
pétersbourgeois des dangers de la neva
et de la mer baltique
notre boulot est difficile on travaille
sous pression on est confronté à des
chocs psychologiques à des risques
emotionnellement c'est dur talât doit
affronter n'importe quelle situation
marc dessinateur français installé
depuis 11 ans affronte lui l'hiver pour
relever un défi insensé sculpter les
plus beaux joyaux du musée de l'ermitage
sur glace je crois qu'aujourd'hui fait
moins neuf moins 10 kg en effet une
température parfaite entre passé et
avenir entre été et hiver c'est la
double vie de saint pétersbourg
[Musique]
le plus souvent le coeur historique de
saint-pétersbourg se découvre par ces
canaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais depuis quelque temps certains
explorent un peu différemment
pour cela il faut savoir braver les
interdits et prendre de la hauteur
bonjour salut je suis nasca achat ou
alors je suis votre guide
quand on ira vers l'immeuble ne fait pas
de bruit ni dans la cour ni dans
l'escalier
[Musique]
la première fois que je vois la ville
c'est magnifique je n'avais encore
jamais vu l'année va comme ça j'ai envie
me baigner riche de son architecture et
de son histoire impérial saint
pétersbourg est devenue en quelques
années la capitale du roofing en russie
et mais qu'est ce qu'il fait pour pacha
le guide la seule vue ne suffit plus
alors la tête dans la neva et les pieds
dans les nuages le panorama prend une
toute autre dimension
moi je suis sous le choc c'est une vue
imprenable
c'est génial de voir la ville comme ça
en hiver elle est en noir et blanc toute
grise et là elle a repris toutes ses
couleurs
à leurs pieds sur la neva une réplique
d'un navire de guerre du xviiie siècle
et la forteresse pierre et paul rappelle
ce que doit encore aujourd'hui la ville
à pierre le grand
son fondateur on va s'asseoir ou sur ça
ici je perçois la ville comme un tout
son esprit son atmosphère
je comprends qu'on est entouré d'eau
c'est ce qui rend cette ville si une
pierre legrand a décidé de construire
cette ville ici on lui a dit mais qu'est
ce que tu fais tu veux construire une
ville sur des marécages et lui a répondu
mais c'est très bien je veux qu'on soit
entouré par l'eau
[Musique]
pendant ce temps sur le fleuve genève à
l'adie mire constructeur naval de
renault se rend à son bureau en bateau
ça c'est la forteresse pierre-et-paul
pour la russie c'est un lieu très
important
de nombreux événements historiques s'y
sont produits mais surtout c'est ici
qu'est né saint pétersbourg la
forteresse a toujours été importante
dans ma vie parce que j'ai grandi juste
de l'autre côté dans le quartier de la
petrograd car notre maison était voisine
de la forteresse
au sommet il ya un an selon ge
protecteur de saint pétersbourg
il ya une dizaine d'années lange a été
retiré pour être restaurées et tous les
habitants ont eu peur de se retrouver
sans sa protection
il a fallu le remplacer au plus vite
attachée aux traditions vladimir dès
qu'il en al'occasion se déplace en
bateau tout comme l'avait imposé pierre
legrand aux riches familles de la ville
mes aïeux vivent à saint petersbourg
depuis des générations et des
générations c'est ma ville je l'est dans
le sens je laime et puis mes enfants et
ma famille sont nés
en grand amoureux de sa ville
l'architecte naval s'est mise en tête de
perpétuer l'oeuvre de pierre le grand
avec andrei son bras droit il nous
emmène sur un chantier titanesque
le projet de sa vie il vient inspecter
les dernières avancées
on
à gauche je vais te montrer quelque
chose
[Musique]
il ne devrait pas y avoir une coursive
vers loi non seulement vers le bas c'est
ce qui fait office d'échafaudages
temporaire la soupe définitive sera
différente
il y a trois ans l'a dit mir s'est mise
au défi de construire à l'identique le
premier navire de guerre dessiné par
pierre legrand lui-même le poltava
[Musique]
dis moi qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
la dernière fois on en voit le bout
il ne reste plus qu'à installer la
dernière cers de la poupe et on aura
tout est parti à lui seul le squelette
du bateau a nécessité deux mille chêne
centenaire
à terme ce monstre des mers mesurera 43
m de long et 40 mètres de haut
et à séparer ses épaules tard à changer
la position de la russie sur la mer
baltique
c'est comme si on comparait une
puissance nucléaire face à une puissance
sans larmes et bien le poltava a fait de
la russie une superpuissance en surtemps
à l'époque pierre legrand employait 500
ouvriers aujourd'hui vladimir n'emploie
que 150 mais tous sont habités par ce
défi hors du temps comme dans un rêve de
petit garçon
fidèle à l'original le poltava du 21e
siècle aura aussi ses canons
je perce un trou pour l'emplacement de
la mèche du canon pour qu'on puisse
tirer c'est par là qu'on fera passer la
mèche mais le canon va tirer en vrai oui
pour de vrai mais vous êtes un
spécialiste en canot non je suis tourné
mais ça me plaît parce que c'est quand
même une histoire qu'on transmet aux
générations futures qui peut être que
nous peut le faire allez on prend la
dernière tiges remontée de 3 mm maxime
31 ans est le responsable de l'atelier
d'emma voilure et cordages c'est lui
l'ouvrier le plus admiré le plus
respecté du chantier on n'est plus dans
les mas c'est le troisième les gens
jeunes et vient justement de sur un plan
où on en est tu vois là ce qui est en
verre c'est déjà fait c'est le grand mec
5 korshunov il a été le capitaine du
standard
le scandale c'était la première frégate
de la flotte russe sur la mer baltique
il a été construit en 1703 sur le
chantier naval de l'ado gars c'est en
carélie et nous nous avons fait la
réplique de ce navire au début des
années 90 à saint pétersbourg j'avais 10
ans quand j'ai rejoint l'équipe du
standard sur des budgets d apporter les
pièces détachées du nationaux ou alors
je les condamne à 10 ans mais comment
c'est possible
vous savez en russie tout est possible
contrairement au standaard qui naviguent
sur tous les océans du globe
le poltava lui restera à quai à son
inauguration
saint petersbourg pourra s'enorgueillir
du plus grand musée flottant du monde
avec ses dimensions hors normes
le pôle tabac serait bien en peine de
naviguer sur la neva
aujourd'hui avenues principales de la
ville le trafic maritime est intense et
les dangers réels
dans la zone sud de la ville une brigade
de sauveteurs plongeurs vient de
recevoir un appel d'urgence
malo
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'informations
apparemment il a été éjecté de son jet
ski
il a besoin d aide c'est tout ce qu'on
sait
été comme hiver les sauveteurs de saint
pétersbourg assure une mission de
service public capitale plus de six
mille interventions par an
nous sommes au mois de juin mais la
température de la neva ne dépasse pas 15
degrés le blessé risque d'hypothermie
vas-y
la mal au bras gauche ou le droit
le gauche comment tu t'appelles sasha
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sacha j'allais
trop vite sur mon jet ski et j'ai été
éjecté et tu as mal où j'ai mal aux bras
et à part le bras jamal ailleurs je suis
non ça va avec sa douleur au bras
le blessé ne pouvait ni remonté sur son
jet ski ni atteindre seule la berge
il est prêt et transportées allez on y
va
on va s'occuper de toi tu vas aller à
l'hôpital
l'année dernière était hiver confondues
les anges gardiens de la neva ont sauvé
la vie de près de 450 personnes
malgré tout 120 ont encore péri dans les
eaux froides de la ville quand tu es
jeune tu as impossible donc pour les
sauveteurs plongeurs de relâcher leur
vigilance à leur tête
youri 34 ans ancien plongeur dans
l'armée c'est lui qui dirige les 400
hommes de la brigade vous attendez le
retour de li ternie et ensuite vous irez
patrouiller le long du quai les autres
sont toujours les mêmes attention moi
j'ai déjà dû intervenir auprès de jeunes
ce soir yuri et ses hommes n'ont pas le
droit à l'erreur
la ville accueille le plus grand
rassemblement de l'année la fête de tous
les bacheliers de russie aujourd'hui
c'est le jour j
le jour de la grande fête certains c'est
du plaisir pour d'autres du moulin je
vais voir mes hommes grenouilles ce sont
les plus importants de la soirée
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bonjour on est très cool tu reprends
s'il se passe quelque chose d marre de
vous informer la centrale 3 vous
intervenez vous êtes bien sur le canal 5
ha ouais vous le dire c'est bien sûr le
oui oui ok alors on communique sur le 5
[Musique]
en ce 21 juin huit cent mille personnes
venues des quatre coins du pays attend
avec impatience le clou de la soirée
c'est le rêve de chaque bachelier à
saint pétersbourg d'assister à cette
fête c'est unique
on a notre bac qu'une fois dans notre
vie c'est comme cette fête ça n'arrive
qu'une fois dans la vie
une seule fois
[Musique]
à minuit le ciel s'enflamme de mille
feux pour accueillir les voiles rouges
un bateau mythique qui symbolise
l'avenir de la jeunesse et le renouveau
de saint pétersbourg
[Musique]
des spectacles comme celui des voiles
écarlates ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde
saint pétersbourg est unique
[Musique]
merci à saint pétersbourg 2006
incroyable et bonne fête à tous les
bacheliers
[Musique]
depuis que poutine le pétersbourgeois le
plus célèbre est devenu maître du
kremlin la ville renaît de ses cendres
et se rêve en phare de la nouvelle
russie
[Musique]
vous
chaque année saint pétersbourg attire
toujours plus de touristes
[Musique]
pour découvrir le coeur de l'ancienne
capitale impériale ses 160 km de canaux
et ses dizaines de ponts le meilleur
moyen reste encore le bateau
voilà l'endroit où aujourd'hui j'ai
dessiné le panorama
marc lui n'est pas un touriste artistes
français installé à saint pétersbourg
depuis 11 ans il a le projet fou de
monter une exposition de tableaux en
glace en attendant des températures
négatives
il profite de l'été pour terminer une
autre oeuvre tout aussi insensé pas
encore fini en trois ans marc a peint un
à un tous les édifices de la prospective
qui les champs-elysées de saint
pétersbourg 9 kilomètres -de
architecture concentrer sur seulement 10
mètres de papier à main levée
une oeuvre unique à laquelle il associe
les passants
c'est un projet c'est pas long j'ai déjà
dessiné 500 personnes et j'aimerais bien
vous dessinez c'est gratuit ça prend
juste cinq minutes vous avez du temps le
tableau ça permet de rencontrer les gens
que les rues sont des fois un petit peu
timide et de m'approcher et quand je les
dessine alors de suite d'un contact et
on peut parler et une histoire j'en
demande d'où ils viennent un point ils
sont ici qui me plaît c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de création de deux créateurs
d'artistes de musiciens et il ya toute
cette énergie que j'aime beaucoup et à
la fois c'est une grande ville et à la
fois il ya des quartiers des petits
ville c'est comme d un petit village
dans la grande ville
c'est un travail titanesque et privés
mais des regarde et je vais tout vous
montrez vous pouvez m'aider
tenez le pour tout montrer la petite
fille voilà voilà
si marc connaît toutes les façades de la
prospective ski il connaît aussi les
trésors cachés
loin des sentiers touristiques pour
arrondir ses maigres revenus d'artistes
il travaille aussi à temps partiel comme
agent immobilier ses clients cet après
midi une mère et son fils tout juste
arrivé de france après la spécialité de
marque dénicher des appartements hors du
commun qu'il propose à la location aux
touristes alors ici c'est le grand
corridor qui dessert toutes les chambres
avec lits qui date de l'époque
soviétique avait cette famille qui
vivait là c'est un kommunalka et il y
avait un téléphone pour tout le monde
vieillit et les gens pouvaient appeler
indéfiniment alors il y avait des tas de
disputes autour du téléphone parce qu'il
joue quel téléphone mais c'était passait
rien c'était gratuit
c'était gratuit à l'époque oui alors
voilà la chambre verte
d'après moi ici vous nous serait bien au
calme et en plus avec une superbe vue
sur le canal
là là là vous êtes au jour le plus long
owni blanche alors qu'il n'y a pas de
voler son très beau c'est rideau mais
vous pouvez les fermer parce que la nuit
vous allez être réveillé à 4 heures du
matin en pleine nuit blanche
il n'y a pas de voler voilà donc
n'hésitez pas sinon vous allez vous
n'avez pas dormir on essaie de garder
l'ambiance un peu soviétique et détenant
de toutes les époques d'ailleurs on
essaye d'être embouti le au maximum il y
a quinze ans dominique bijoutière de
formation est venu s'installer à saint
pétersbourg depuis elle est devenue plus
russe que les russes tout comme son
appartement alors oui si c'est la salle
de bain tout en bois devriez c'est très
chaleureux pour prendre son bain c'est
très bien valve a vu un peu à peu dur
c'est typiquement de stelios qui
n'oublie pas qu'on a dans le quartier de
l'ophite au yen monnaies d'un quartier
d'un seuil est scott en fait rentrer le
côté canal et l'intérieur de la cour on
n'est pas du tout dans la même ambiance
mais pour cacher et ouais un peu sordide
c'est en tout cas ce à la russie il
écoutera ce qui contraste
mais ferrer voilà c'est très bien votre
cas maison alors en à votre arrivée à
votre beau séjour ici j'essaie de tout
des appartements qui ont du charme qui
on va se rappeler de
et où ou l'art la russie
saint-pétersbourg les couleurs présentes
au plus fort de l'été à ces latitudes le
soleil ne se couche pas avant minuit
ce sont les fameuses nuits blanches
si le sénateur je passe à bâbord
ce spectacle touristes et
pétersbourgeois viennent observer sur
les quais et sur les bateaux mouches
ils se pressent aussi pour y admirer le
travail d'un homme un homme que personne
ne connaît pourtant véritables maîtres
de la ville
[Musique]
attac boyer
moi je suis comme un policier qui fait
la circulation un carrefour j'ai réguler
la circulation dans tous les sens
seulement je suis à la manoeuvre d'une
technologie ultra puissante de
mécanismes super puissant d'une machine
méga puissant depuis 34 ans sergueï est
aux manettes du pont le plus emprunté de
la ville le pont du palais 1800 tonnes
d'acier et un million de boulot
il est une heure 23 il ne reste plus que
deux minutes et c'est des entrailles du
géant que sergei impose ses règles aux
noctambules la sécurité j'ai peint
signalisation la circulation arrêté de
moyens de passer d'une rive à l'autre
saint pétersbourg se retrouve coupée en
bout attention je lève les ailes du pont
et voilà c'est lancé
à
[Musique]
regardez le spectacle que je vous offre
chaque nuit les treize ponts de la ville
laisse circuler les gros navires sur la
neva saint pétersbourg devient alors un
carrefour maritime majeur
[Musique]
en fait notre route fluviale en russie a
été pensé pour qu'on ne puisse pas
éviter saint pétersbourg lorsque les
navires arrivent d'europe et qu'ils se
rendent au centre de la russie
ils doivent obligatoirement passer par
ici par la neva la de la dauga et
ensuite peuvent atteindre le nord et le
sud le centre de la russie
c'est intéressant
l'homme dont la base c'est mon fils
cadet qui est aux commandes ce soir mon
fils aîné travail sur le pont tout stoff
toute ma famille lève les ponts mois de
fils à ma faim
à 2h30 du matin le jour pointe déjà à
l'horizon
les amoureux des nuits blanches eux
profitent d'une dernière valse avant la
fin de l'été
[Musique]
sans avoir vrai
dès début novembre saint petersbourg
doit affronter un hiver polaire
les températures peuvent descendre
jusqu'à moins 30
emmitouflés les habitants apprennent dès
leur plus jeune âge à résister aux
conditions climatiques extrêmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour mastia le froid n'est pas un
problème c'est même son élément
cette jeune femme de 24 ans est
championne de nage en eau froide
une pratique typiquement russe qu'elle
va faire découvrir aujourd'hui à ses
amis l'eau à l'air super hot wave en
plus il fait vraiment bon
il fait bon c'est ce qu'il nous faut
dans ce bassin creusé au milieu d'un
petit lac sportifs confirmés amateurs
s'entraîne tout l'hiver dans une eau à 1
degrés température extérieure ce jour-là
moins 5 degrés la spécialité de nastia
c'est le 50 m 50 m et pas un de plus
nager davantage pourrait entraîner un
arrêt cardiaque et hypothermie
[Musique]
oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
je viens âges et tous les week-ends
pendant la semaine
j'ai accumulé beaucoup de stress et donc
là je m'en débarrasse
c'est comme si je reconnaissais ça me
redonne des forces
je me sens en pleine forme et prête à
affronter la semaine qui vient au tour
d'andrei de relever le challenge
une première pour lui
oh la vache
c'est comme si on m'avait retourné la
tête comme si je revenais d'une autre
planète
ah c'était super je reprends tout juste
les esprits quand je suis sorti de l'eau
je savais plus où j'étais
ça m'a regonflé à bloc je pensais pas
que j'en serai capable 25 mètres d'un
coup t'as pas eu peur ça va ah ouais
super tu vois comme l'hiver nous fait du
bien tous les deux dans la famille de
nastia tout le monde des nageurs en eaux
froides sa mère olga professeur de piano
il a initié dès l'âge de deux ans les
voilà les photos elles sont vieilles et
tout décoller ces crises et voilà le
moment quatre mois mais d'abord c'est
moi qui me suis trempé dans un triste
creusé dans la glace j'avais l'air si
heureuse que mes enfants ont voulu faire
pareil
monfils avait 11 ans ma fille 2 ils ont
voulu essayer
après ils se sont sentis si bien ils
étaient tous joyeux et surtout si fiers
de vous pendant toute son enfance la
petite nastia se trompent
une fois par semaine dans l'eau glacée à
l'adolescence elle assiste à une
compétition de natation
une révélation c'était au bord d'un lac
entouré de montagnes
c'était vraiment beau l'eau était à 4
degrés j'ai voulu aller juste me tremper
comme je fais d'habitude
et puis tout d'un coup je me suis dit
mais pourquoi est-ce que je ne nagerai
pas et je les fais tout une longueur 25
mètres autant devient tout de suite
après j'ai foncé m'inscrire à la
compétition à la dernière minute
depuis ça fait six ans que je participe
à des compétitions
de l'or en estonie de l'argent en
slovénie elle enchaîne les victoires
cet esprit sportif et très ancrée chez
nastia elle veut toujours être la
première partout dans quelques jours
nastia se rendra au plus grand
rassemblement de baigneurs en eaux
froides de la ville
loin des quartiers populaires au pied de
la cathédrale saint nicolas des marins
marque le dessinateur prépare son
exposition de tableaux en glace pour
choisir les toiles il va tenter de
reproduire
il se rend avec son fils dan hill au
musée de l'ermitage profiter de la glace
ancien palais des tares et joyau de
l'architecturé baroque russe
l'ermitage c'est le symbole de saint
pétersbourg mais également avec ses 1000
salles l'un des plus grands musées du
monde
bonjour madame bonjour
même s'il a déjà visité à plusieurs
reprises marque a fait appel à une guide
pour ne pas se perdre dans le musée et
se noyer dans ces quelques 3 millions
d'oeuvres d'art tous les murs mois à
droite et à gauche sont recouverts de
petits portraits souvent de porter des
généraux russes
les petits formats ce sont des porteurs
des généraux
garde un peu tout cet or madame indique
avait vingt kilos d'or
nous arrivons à une des oeuvres
capitales
mathis de la pollution ah bah voilà qui
s'appelle la ronde larron non celle à
laquelle c'est le nom que macky sall
avait donné du mal à cette heure 1 ac
voilà cela daniel il nous plaît ça c'est
vraiment tout le monde connaisse et
l'ermitage ses matisse on veut peinture
je vis ce tableau déjà par sa taille
parce que nous on a un grand tableau et
puis par les couleurs qui sont simples
et puis par c'est par ce rythme ce
mouvement et puis à trois couleurs donc
je pense qu avec de la glace on va y
arriver
et comme si reproduire des tableaux en
glace n'était pas déjà assez complexe
marc l'excentrique a décidé de corser
encore un peu plus le défi est là tiens
regarde presque en fait on pourra même y
trouver un verre et le coller dans la
glace comme ça on aura besoin de
s'amuser à faire le vert bien que le
verre la perspective les toute tordue ça
va être très dur de trouver un verbe cru
je voulais prendre picasso parce que
picasso c'est c'était mon voisin pendant
onze ans on habitait à 700 mètres l'un
de l'autre à lui à mougins
il est décédé en 1973 je me rappelle
encore de tous les drapeaux français qui
était devant sa propriété
on a les mêmes acheter le pain à la même
boulangerie et tous les autres tableaux
de picasso sans trop dur à faire en
glace et celui-là c'est quand même le un
des plus simples après matisse et
picasso
marc voudrait aussi rendre hommage au
peintre russe voilà furet super de table
au real et belles couleurs
bah voilà le titre parfait zim daniel
l'hiver un basculeur à le prendre
j'ai même pas besoin de regarder les
autres
marc est emballé par un tableau de
kandinsky je pouvais pas trouver mieux
je savais même pas qu'il existait c'est
le tableau qu'il faut il ya de la glace
il ya de la neige et à des montagnes le
froid je le bleu et toutes les couleurs
voilà est né là à les compléter
pendant ce temps au pied de l'ermitage
du riz et son équipe font leur tournée
d'inspection quotidienne sur le golfe de
finlande en hiver sur la mer gelée les
risques de noyade et d'accidents mortels
sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'en été
si les gens c'est un territoire et si
oui
premières victimes les pêcheurs sur
glace
allez on est parti la première consigne
c'est de ne pas aller sur la glace si
elle fait moins de 7 10 cm d'épaisseur
en particulier pour ceux qui viennent en
voiture sur la glace et puis je leur
explique les premiers gestes de survie
sûr que le yoga le gardon voilà un
sandre mais je les pêcher un peu plus
loin suis là la glace est épaisse ici
elle atteint 30 cm non non 15 cm
peut-être voir 20 15 20 cm c'est pas mal
allez on mesure la glace il ya sûrement
des hommes qui tombent à travers la
glace dans le golfe de finlande dans la
neva et là l'expérience et l'excellence
de sauveteurs plongeurs est déterminante
puisque chaque seconde est vital pour
sauver un homme à l'eau on vient de
mesurer la glace sur la neva le faisait
33 cm même avec le passage du brise
glace ça fait même plus ici 35 cette
année la glace est bonne bon je vous
donne ça quand vous aurez minutes lisez
le c'est important quand même bien je le
ferai bien discuté avec des gars comme
vous parce que parfois on a affaire des
pêcheurs bourré et la foule leur parler
autrement à mais nous on est sobre
j'ai 74 ans ça fait déjà bien 20 ans que
je pêche sur la glace et je ne suis
jamais tombé à l'eau
[Musique]
voyez comme une artiste suis là je lui
retire son hameçon pour qu'il grandisse
encore un peu
aujourd'hui yuri a un emploi du temps
chargé
lui et ses hommes doivent creuser un
bassin dans la glace pour le futur
rassemblement des nageurs en eau froide
admirez bon vous êtes au courant de
dimension
vous savez quelle distance il faut
creuser c'est quoi la profondeur de 4
mètres 1 mètre 50
en plein mois de janvier la surface du
fleuve est aussi dur que l'acier
peu à peu les sauveteurs dessine une
croix dans quelques jours des milliers
de croyants
viendront s'y baigner pour célébrer le
baptême du christ
une tradition risqué que youri doit
sécuriser ouvre toi vite comme ça ça
prend ses précautions indispensables
yuri demande à ses hommes d'explorer le
fond de la neva il plonge pour vérifier
le fond de l'eau s'il n'y a rien qui
pourrait empêcher l'installation de la
structure en bois mais qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait trouver mon sens on peut
trouver des déchets carcasse de métal ou
même à noyers à l'eau tu vois le fond il
ya quelque chose
bon maintenant on dégage les lieux il ne
reste plus rien tout est enfin prêt pour
la touche finale comme descendus des
cieux une chapelle est posée au fond du
fleuve
[Musique]
de retour à leur base les sauveteurs
plongeurs s'accordent une pause avant
leur prochaine mission
après des heures passées dans le froid
ils se sont préparés du cendrier du
golfe de finlande
faute ou manger même la tête faut pas
jeter c'est trop bon les sauveteurs
plongeurs seront de garde toute la nuit
à ces latitudes septentrionales en hiver
la nuit tombe dès 16 heures
oh
il est 10 heures le jour se lève enfin
bien dormi 1 infinite arrière la femme
n'a rien dit et lui c'est au nom de
l'art depuis deux semaines marc
l'artiste français travaillent 18 heures
par jour pour finir à temps ses tableaux
en glace tous les matins il retrouve ses
assistants dans l'arrière-cour de son
immeuble transformé en atelier pour
l'occasion d'un genre bien dormi alors
aujourd'hui je vais faire le toit et
après il faut préparer les couleurs pour
verser pour la maison va donc votes tu
veux cette couleur à la wii jaune et du
vert
on peut faire ses fenêtres cinq nominés
milliards ensemble ils préparent la
future exposition de marque coop
je crois que j'aurais peut-être orfèvres
mon voisin parce qu'il m'a dit pourquoi
vous travaillez pas l'intérieur
il n'arrivait pas le croire il a pris la
glace marque doit terminer un tableau de
monet très compliqué à copier un à un
chaque trait de pinceau et remplacés par
des morceaux de glaces teintées
déjà je les mets dans l'eau chaude
seringue et gelé le pass pur de l'eau ni
trop chaudes ni trop froides en guise de
colle tout est question de température
je crois qu'aujourd'hui fait moins 10 -
9 - dix clubs et c'est une température
parfaite
- 8 c'est trop chaud la chaleur de ma
main va vite faire fondre la glace et
moins 20 c trop froid pour mes pieds par
contre la glace elle est parfaite et pas
main enfin moi j'aime bien les
conditions extrêmes marc a prévu de
présenter cinq tableaux au public le
jour du vernissage de son exposition
le travail presque terminé ne reste plus
qu'à tracer les lignes noires sur
l'hiver de kandinsky et à prier
[Musique]
si la température et chauffe on sera
obligé de leur dire au revoir
ils partiront dans la rivière
[Musique]
en attendant l'exposition de marque
en cette journée du 18 janvier au pied
de la forteresse pierre et paul on
célèbre l'épiphanie
[Applaudissements]
depuis la chute de l'urss on assiste en
russie à la renaissance de la foi
orthodoxe et de ses rites
parmi les milliers de fidèles venus
aujourd'hui se baigner dans l'eau bénite
du fleuve
nastia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
aujourd'hui c'est un jour particulier
on fait tous ensemble l'épiphanie je
suis vraiment contente
heureuse de m'être baigner ici
aujourd'hui et puis c'est tellement bu
le sang russe où sa chaleur dans le
froid
comme l'a dit un célèbre écrivain
mais le froid n'est pas sans risque en
cas d'hydrocution la protection de dieu
ne suffit pas les sauveteurs plongeurs
veille
[Applaudissements]
je vous aide non merci peut-être quand
je remonterai exceptionnellement youri a
délaissé son uniforme réglementaire de
sauveteurs attention les gars voilà
notre directeur attention attention
oh oh seigneur
[Musique]
je suis sûr je me sens recharger à fond
je suis plein d'énergie prêts à
travailler beaucoup et longtemps à
retourner le monde
avec l'aide de dieu après le choc
thermique
tous les moyens sont bons pour se
réchauffer
[Musique]
cette année trente mille croyant auront
affronté les eaux glacées de la neva
[Musique]
on
une semaine plus tard un réchauffement
inhabituelle a transformé la ville en
véritable pataugeoire marque est
inquiète pour ses tableaux
mais vers la neige à la façon du bail la
température cette nuit est monté 1° 2°
maintenant et il pleut en plus alors il
a fallu faire un sarcophage pour les
oeuvres d'art pour pas qu'elle fonde sa
c'est l'oeuvre maîtresse et mathis y
pleut maintenant le vernissage de
marquer compromis
les heures sont comptées
[Musique]
il retire
par en devenir
[Musique]
il n'a pas prévu un gyrophare
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marc a prévu de faire son exposition
éphémère au pied des colonnes rostrales
en face de l'ermitage sur les bords de
la neva
c'est lourd on pose sans autorisation
l'artiste doit faire vite pour ne pas
être repéré par la police
on peut le faire glisser pour plus de
discrétion
l'exposition sauvages ne commencera qu'à
la nuit tombée
il faut tout retirer le plexiglas aussi
ont tiré par les jeux regarder une
minute il a changé un peu mais le
profond du chevalet cadre éclairage les
copies des tableaux de l'ermitage vont
être dévoilé en grande pompe
nana je sois prêt qui a brillé
[Musique]
la ronde de marque et fidèle à
l'original de matisse
ima et l'hiver de kandinsky
s'en suivent la meule de foin de monnaie
voilà
ouais le clou du spectacle un picasso en
relief
et du vin pour picasso
donc alyssa merci alyssa et alexei merci
de m'avoir supporté ce sont des gens si
calme contrairement à moi qui suis
volcaniques
pour couronner son succès marque peut
compter sur un feu d'artifice inattendue
sans le savoir
l'artiste français a organisé son
exposition le soir de la célébration de
la fin du siège de leningrad en 1945
saint petersbourg la ville où tout est
possible
brille à nouveau de tous ses feux